Das war's für heute.
Ich hoffe, dass ich euch gefallen habe.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
dann schreibt mir in die Kommentare,
was ihr noch mehr von uns sehen wollt.
Vielen Dank für's Zuschauen.
Schreibt mir in die Kommentare, was ihr noch mehr von uns sehen wollt.
Wenn ihr mehr von uns sehen wollt,
dann schreibt mir in die Kommentare,
was ihr noch mehr von uns sehen wollt.
Ich habe mich gemutet. Ah, excellent. Wunder mich schon. Oh, nee, ich glaube ich habe einen
Wackelkontakt. Kann das sein? Oh. Monk... Monka... Monarch S. Wackelkontakt. Wackelkontakt
in meinem kack Verlängerungskabel. Was ist denn da los? Das geht aber nicht. Verlängerungskabel
brauche ich. Dankeschön für den Sub Martin. Huge Big Brain Sub. Du hattest gerade einen
Rauschen. Jetzt haben wir wieder gut, oder? Wieso gibt es nicht mal einen Linux hier?
Es gibt gar keine. Ich mauze. Oh, ich habe die Umfrage vom letzten Mal noch offen. Wo davon
ist es gar nicht abgekackt? Ah, gleich wieder am Start. So. Ja, ich glaube ich habe irgendwie...
Entweder bin ich mal zu viel mit dem Stuhl über das Kabel gerollt, wo ich eigentlich
aufpasse, dass es nicht so oft passiert, oder das Verlängerungskabel kackt wirklich ab.
Man weiß es nicht. Ah, Axi, stimmt, wollte ich noch machen, ja. Du hast recht, ich habe
nämlich das Repo angelegt. Ich habe nämlich das Repo angelegt und dann habe ich nichts
reingepusht. Stimmt, komm mal da. Warum hat das jemand geforkt? Da ist nichts drinnen.
Sascha, warum hast du das geforkt? Da ist nichts drinnen. Ja, mache ich, habe ich ganz
vergessen. Hab ich komplett vergessen. Ja, habe ich wirklich ernsthaft komplett vergessen.
Leute, ich habe nur Stream angemacht, weil ich so lange nicht mehr gestreamt habe. Ich
habe nämlich heute mal geguckt und habe festgestellt, es ist schon wieder vier Tage. Hab ich euch
jetzt Mist erzählt? Aber ich bilde mir ein, das war aber nicht gesehen, um vier Tage.
Jaja. Ah, stimmt. Und mittlerweile sieht übrigens auch Twitch anders aus. Das ist voll MonkaS.
Da findest du nichts hier. Da findest du nichts. Wie kommst du denn? Wie kommt man jetzt auf
die Videos? Irgendwie so, oder? Ah, excellent, verstehe. Und wozu hat das jetzt hier so einen
hässlichen Rand, Alter? Das ist ein Cancer Layout. Was ist das denn? Das sieht da mega
hässlich aus, Alter. Ja, nee, ich wusste das. Ich hatte es ja vorhin auch schon gefunden.
Nee, guck mal hier. Vier Tage, sag ich doch. Deswegen, Valorant Key, nö. Gibt's die
jetzt oder was? Gibt's die jetzt? Kriegt jetzt jeder eine Valorant Key? Ich hab mir
jetzt überlegt, ob ich mir eine Valorant Key besorgen soll oder nicht. Aber ich hab
gedacht, ich fahr noch mal ein bisschen. Ach, das ist Mario Kart Musik, ja. Bisschen laut.
Hä? Warum hab ich denn die IRK auf? Oh, die Emotes sind noch ein bisschen klein. Besser.
Ja, ich pushe da nachher was rein. Genau, nachdem ich festgestellt hab, der letzte Stream
ist, wie gesagt, jetzt schon wieder vier Tage her, bin ich extra mal online gekommen.
Eigentlich wollte ich heute Abend gar nicht online kommen, sondern weiter ein bisschen
Modern Warfare spielen. Ich bin ja in den letzten drei Tage übelst am Modern Warfare
grinden. Allerdings zum größten Teil Warzone und ein bisschen Tour-en-Tout. Allerdings,
muss ich sagen, der normale Multiplayer ist richtig scheiße. Ich hab jetzt ja ein paar
mal einen normalen Multiplayer gespielt zum Waffen anlocken und das Einzige, was in diesem
Spiel halbwegs erträglich ist, sind die Spielmodi, die noch schlechter sind. Ist schwierig zu
erklären, aber normalerweise hab ich ja in Call of Duty am liebsten Free-for-all und
ein bisschen, vielleicht ein bisschen Team Bestmensch dominieren. Am liebsten hab ich
eigentlich Free-for-all gespielt. Allerdings ist jeder normale Spielmodus in Modern Warfare
so extrem krass passives Ecken abamen, dass du dir fast schon vorkommst, als bist du irgendwie
in CS und deswegen spiel ich am liebsten, um Waffen zu anlocken, einfach stinknormales,
wie heißt diese Playlist, Shipment und Rust und Shoot House und sowas. Das ist zwar eigentlich
richtiger Müll, aber es ist deutlich erträglicher als der normale Multiplayer, einfach weil
es total hirnlos respawn, ballern, respawn, respawn, ballern, ballern, respawn ist. Der
normale Multiplayer regt auf. Genau, so siehts aus. Ne, der normale Multiplayer ist wirklich
Müll, finde ich. So und was allerdings Spaß macht, was ich nicht erwartet hätte ist,
Tour and Tour macht Spaß. Ich hab gestern irgendwie 12 Runden oder so gespielt, nicht
einmal verloren, was allerdings an meine Mitspieler lag und nicht an mir. Und Warzone macht auch
Spaß, wobei ich sagen muss, dass mir Solo Warzone nicht so wahnsinnig Spaß macht. Solo
Warzone krankt so ein bisschen da dran, wie der normale Multiplayer. Autsch, vor mein
Arm verdreht irgendwie. Krankt so ein bisschen wie der normale Multiplayer, dass es halt
extremes rumgeschimmelt ist. Und ich hab halt kein Bock, 20 Minuten zu spielen und 5 Gegner
zu sehen. Man kann natürlich auch krass auf Kills spielen, das geht auch, allerdings
ist es dann halt sehr random. Mal machst du 11 Kills in irgendwie 5 Minuten oder 3
Minuten oder so und mal ein bisschen direkt down. Also es ist schwierig, also am meisten
Bock macht Warzone mit mehreren Leuten. Ich bräuchte irgendeinen, der mich mal ein bisschen
coacht in dem Game. Ohne Scheiß. Also mal observed, geguckt, wie ich spiele und mir
dann ein paar Tipps gibt. Weil so holt man schneller auf, dass man jetzt einfach 2 Monate
hinten dran ist mit Game üben. Frag den Patrick, der krasse Warzone-Owner mit 6 Kills. 11 Kills
war so ein Beispiel. Das war glaube ich das Game mit den höchsten Kills, was ich bisher
hatte, war 11 Kills auf, die Map ist immer die gleiche oder? Warzone ist immer die gleiche
Map, oder? Da bin ich in der Mitte abgesprungen auf dem Teil der Map, der aussieht wie die
Ground War Map. Es ist schwierig Warzone Call of Duty Modern Warfare Maps zu beschreiben,
die sind, in dem Game sehen die alle irgendwie so hingeklatscht aus. Und in diesen Industriehäusern,
da ging es halt übelst ab. Ich habe übrigens Subs übersehen, glaube ich. Dom PC 5 Monate,
excellent Subscription, huge. Dankeschön für den Sub und wen haben wir hier noch? Den
Arrow, OD, Twitch Prime. Wahnsinn. Big Brain Subscribers bitte. Ähm, Matt, da verlernt
man aber nichts. Er schreibt gerade, er schreibt hier gerade, ähm, habe ich es eigentlich
hier mitgeloggt? Ne. Er schreibt gleich, ich soll ein Video hochladen, dann kommen ja relativ
schnell die Experten, die mir sagen, was ich falsch mache. Das ist ungefähr wie, also
wenn man auf YouTube Kommentare hört, was man in seinem Gameplay verbessern soll, dann
ist das ungefähr so, wie wenn man sich, ähm, bei MMOs an Reddit orientiert. Das ist so,
das gibt so ein paar Dinge, die gehen immer nach hinten los. Die YouTube Comments sind
einfach nur Bullshit von Leuten, die selbst keine Ahnung haben, in 90% der Fälle. Und,
ähm, Leute, die MMOs spielen und auf Reddit rumspammen dazu, was OP ist und was schlecht
ist und sonst was sacken einfach nur in dem Game meistens. Was eigentlich gerade so für
Trends auf GitHub. Zum Beispiel, es gibt ein richtig gutes Beispiel, warum Reddit sackt,
also in dem Fall, warum Reddit voller Noobs ist. Ich hab die letzte Season Path of Exile
gespielt, als Ultra Noob. Ich hab das Spiel gespielt, ein bisschen, als es rausgekommen
ist, auch mit dem Frisör zusammen. Und danach hab ich ewig nicht mehr gespielt. So. Letzte
Season hab ich mir bis ein paar Builds durchgelesen, hab relativ schnell den Build identifiziert,
der absolut Noobstyle für jeden Volldeb zu spielen ist und hab angefangen. Und ich hab
nebenbei immer ein bisschen Forum und Reddit gelesen und ich dachte am Anfang, ich brauch
ein Build, was maximal so 5-6 Chaos Orbs kostet, weil ein Build, was viel kostet, ist kein
richtiges Build und so. Totaler Schwachsinn. Reddit, Alter. Reddit. Feels Reddit, man.
Totaler Bullshit. Ähm, ich hab dann gespielt und ich hatte, glaub ich, schon, als ich im
Endgame angekommen bin, 20 Chaos Orbs oder so. Es ist total hingeklebt. Reddit. Reddit
ist einfach nur voller Kacknoobs. Real Reno sagt, hey, du bist doch dieser Commentary-Typ,
den ich vor ein paar Jahren mal gefeiert hab. Das kann ich, das weiß ich nicht, ob ich
das bin. Möglich wär's. Also wenn du den hier meinst, wenn du den hier meinst, ähm,
dann bin ich das nicht. Ich hör mich nur ähnlich an. Den Keks hab ich nur geklaut,
ja. Na, ich war halt ziemlicher Max-Fanboy und dann hab ich den Keks leicht abgeändert
und auch auf Twitch genommen. So, also was trendet denn heute auf GitHub? Was gibt's
denn da Schönes? Mr. Whip, warum hast du denn, warum hast du denn dieses Video jetzt
rausgesucht? Das ist ja uralt. Guck mal, was er hier für ein Video rausgefischt hat. Ja,
ja, Achtung, Achtung. Kennt das noch jemand? Ja, 2011. Lass das gemeinsam, nein, das konnten
wir nicht gemeinsam. Das ist eine, es ist zwei Stunden. What the fuck? Was haben wir denn
bitte schon zwei Stunden gelabert, ey? 1200 Comments, Alter. Ich muss euch was ekliges
erzählen, Leute. Ich weiß nicht, ob mir's wirklich nicht gut, ob mir's irgendwie ein
bisschen übel ist oder ob das nur so eingebildet ist. Und zwar, ich hab vorhin, äh, bevor
ich Stream angemacht hab, hab ich in der Küche unten gesessen, hab ein Brötchen gefuttert
und hab halt ein Glas Wasser eingeschränkt, Glas Wasser ausgedrungen. Ich trinke, also,
ich trinke immer alles auf einmal. Also, ich schütte, ich mach das Glas von unten bis
oben voll und dann mach ich das ganze Glas weg. Also, selten mal mit absetzen zwischendurch.
So, und während ich das so leer trinke, ne, dann hebt man das Glas immer weiter nach oben
und während ich das so leer trinke, kann man ja so durch das Glas durchschauen. Und
ich trinke das so und ich denke mir auf der Rückseite, vom Glas hängt was. So, dann trinke
ich weiter, trinke ich weiter und sehe, hä, warum hängt auf diesem komischen Stück Dreck
oder so unten am Glas, warum sind da Blasen drauf. Trinke ich weiter und stell fest, äh,
der Dreck ist innen im Glas drinne. Da hab ich halt, hab ich halt abgesetzt und da war
unten, unten am Boden vom Glas, war so ein daumennagelgroßer Stück Schleim. Ich hab
keine Ahnung, was es ist. Sah übelst eklig aus. Da hab ich natürlich nicht weitergeschirrt
und gleich weggeschirrt, aber es war schon eklig, ja. Und ich hab keine Ahnung, was
ich da, was ich da im Glas drinne hab. Ja, aber ich hab meinen Mundschutz auf. Leute,
genauso eklig wie der Chat jetzt tut, war das auch. Deswegen trinkt man aus der Flasche,
das geht nicht. Ich kann nicht, ich kann nicht ähm aus der Flasche trinken. Geht nicht,
also geht wirklich nicht, weil ich hab keine Flasche, ich hab keine Flasche im eigentlichen
Sinn. Ich hab sowas hier. Soda Club Sprudler. Sowas da hab ich. Allerdings mit solchen,
solche Plastikflaschen hier. Da kann man nicht raustrinken aus den Flaschen. Aus dem
Wasserhahn, alter. Nee, Wasser, ich trink, ich mag kein stilles Wasser. Das muss ich,
muss gespudelt sein. Und mittlerweile, ich hab, ich hab das ja schon, keine Ahnung,
15 Jahre oder so. Wir haben das lange, dieses Zeug schon hier. Und also solche Geräte und
ich hab mich so an den Geschmack gewöhnt von unserem Leitungswasser hier, dass mir
jedes andere Wasser gar nicht mehr schmeckt. Und das ekligste Wasser finde ich ist, warte
mal, ist das Haccia, das grüne? Ist das grüne Wasser Haccia? Nee. Äh nee, Bad, Bad, Filbler
Quelle oder so gibt's da noch? Das da. Ur- Quelle. Ey, das schmeckt total eklig. Ach,
was ist der Name? Bad Filbler Ur- Quelle. Dann lieber noch die Rheinfels Quelle, falls
ihr noch einer auf YouTube kennt. Das schmeckt eklig. Schmeckt so, als wäre da irgendwie
Salz reingemischt oder irgendwas. Hanauer Leitungswasser, beste. Sei euch. Monkabär,
Monack Ess. Das Wasser in Deutschland ist so gut, kann man immer trinken, das stimmt.
Wie heißt dieses Wasser nochmal? Was die destillieren und danach wieder Salz und Zeugs
zusetzen, dass es immer gleich schmeckt? Da gibt's irgend so ein Markenwasser, wo die
Wasser destillieren und danach wieder umwandeln. Überkinger? Was zum Geier ist Überkinger?
Hört sich an wie irgendeine spanische Pornseite. Nee, hab ich noch nie gehört. Was? Fiji?
Hab ich auch noch nie gehört. Ist das das? Das könnte das sein, ja. Ja, ich glaub das
ist das. Ich glaub das ist das. Das könnte das wirklich sein. Nee, oder? Nee, nee, das
ist es nicht, nein. Es könnte Apollinaris sein, was ich meine. Ich bin mir aber nicht
erkannt, ich aus total bescheuert. Total bescheuert erstmal. Der Kommentator ist da, Ruby. Also
was trendet denn aktuell gerade so auf GitHub? Zeig mal her. Deno, ja das wollten wir uns
auch mal im Stream angucken. Ich hab die Existenzberechtigung noch nicht so ganz verstanden ehrlich gesagt
von Deno, weil das wichtigste an Javascript sind eigentlich die 30 Milliarden Pakete die
es gibt. Wenn ich die alle nicht verwenden kann, warum soll ich dann Deno verwenden?
Das verstehe ich noch nicht. Naja, gut. Dann trendet noch irgendwelche Corona Simulationen.
Ey, ich sag ja in letzter Zeit wenig über Corona und sonst was. Ich rant immer immer
zwei Minuten und so, aber ich muss jetzt mal was loswerden, weil aktuell, wenn man auf
Twitter guckt, ne? Schauen wir mal. Twitter Trends. Ach nee. Ah nee, es trendet gerade
irgendwelche AfD-Geschichten. Okay, das kommt auch zu abwechselnd immer mal wieder. Genau,
also es trendet ja total oft auf Twitter gerade irgendwelche Verschwörungsgeschichten und
dann Leute, die sich lächerlich machen über Verschwörungsleute. Dann gibt es welche,
die sagen, wir sind besorgt wegen Corona-Maßnahmen. Dann gibt es Leute, die posten an ihr, wie
heißt das? Covid-Idioten. Ihr seid ja alle total bescheuert. Also quasi jeder versucht
mal wieder die Welt zu verbessern auf Twitter. Und was dabei total untergeht, ist, ähm,
ich muss mal kurz überlegen, wie ich das am besten ausdrücke. Also was da komplett
untergeht, ist, dass es durchaus von allen beteiligten Parteien, also Parteien mache
ich jetzt Leute, unterschiedliche Gruppierungen, die an diesen Sachen da beteiligt sind, dass
alle die ein oder anderen sinnvollen Punkte haben. Allerdings, sobald du zum Beispiel
auf Twitter schreibst, was ist denn gerade angesagt, ja hier Freiheit wird wegen Corona
eingeschränkt, hast du gleich die Leute, die dann übelst drauf abgehen, Max, du willst
das Leute verrecken, oder wenn du umgedreht schreibst, ich glaube, ich hab ja gepostet,
man kann den Leuten schlicht und ergreifend nicht trauen, sich an Maßnahmen zu halten,
deswegen wird es wahrscheinlich wieder hochgehen. Da kamen auch schon die ersten, die gesagt
haben, das hat doch alles nichts gebracht, Shutdown umsonst, ganze Maßnahmen umsonst,
wir werden verarscht. Also sprich, egal was du sagst, die andere Seite springt immer komplett
drauf, was halt total untergeht ist, dass alle Seiten, wenn man mal genau guckt, schon sinnvolle
Punkte haben und ein Punkt, wo ich da an sich bin, dass der viel zu wenig angesprochen
wird ist, da wirst du aber auch schon wieder gesteinigt auf Twitter, wenn du das schreibst,
oder? Ich sehe die Einschränkungen der Grundrechte in Deutschland auch kritisch, aber ich sag
nicht, dass es unsinnig ist. Man muss sich mal überlegen, wie man, also man könnte das
viel besser an die Leute kommunizieren, warum man Sachen macht, und das vermisse ich ein
bisschen. Zum Beispiel, wenn man jetzt sagt, Leute, bleiben wir mal bei einem ganz einfachen
Beispiel, wenn man sagt, Leute, alle Eisdielen müssen dicht machen, weil Corona. So, dann
ist das erstmal, man stellt die Leute vor vollendete Tatsachen und sagt, weil Corona,
die Sache ist bloß die, weil Corona ist keine sinnvolle Begründung. Man müsste, und das
würde auch den ganzen Verschwörungstheorien vorbeugen, und das würde auch, das würde
sehr viele Sachen vorbeugen, wenn man die Maßnahmen, die man trifft, ordentlich erklärt.
Also sprich, wenn man sagt, ja, wir haben jetzt ABC-Maßnahmen beschlossen, und wir
haben diese Maßnahmen beschlossen aus diesen und diesen Gründen, wir haben uns überlegt,
was man sonst noch machen kann. Uns ist bewusst, dass man zum Beispiel hier schon stark in
die Grundrechte eingreift, aber wir sind zu dem Schluss gekommen, das geht nicht anders,
weil so und so, wir haben uns die und die Punkte überlegt, aber die funktionieren aus diesen
Gründen nicht, deswegen müssen wir es so machen. So, und wenn man das machen würde,
dann würden das auch vielen Sachen vorbeugen. Glaubst du, dass die Leute so eine lange Aufmerksamkeit
sparen haben? Na, wenn die Leute so doof sind, mal zwei Minuten sich das anzugucken, da haben
sie halt gelitten, aber es würden allen anderen total den Wind aus den Segeln nehmen. Die,
die sich das geben, denken, selbst das glaube ich nicht. Nachdenken ist nicht so verbreitet.
Das müsste man erklären. Dann nimmst du komplett den anderen Seiten auch den Wind aus den Segeln,
dann kommt keiner mehr an und erzählt, dass irgendwie Bill Gates die Leute zwangsimpfen
will und mit Mikrochips versorgen will und sonst was und das im Deckmantel der Corona-Maßnahmen
und bla und sonst was. Man muss, wenn man Entscheidungen trifft, das ist jetzt nicht
nur so von oben, von der Regierung herab, man muss eigentlich immer, wenn man Entscheidungen
trifft, die Auswirkungen auf Leute haben, muss man die erklären können. Wenn man die
erklären kann, dann ist die Chance relativ gut, dass die Leute es zumindest nachvollziehen
können, warum was passiert und man überzeugt Leute viel einfacher damit, wenn man ihnen
erklärt, warum man was macht, als wenn man ihnen einfach sagt, wir machen das und so
ist es. Seit wann interessieren sich Verschwörungstheoretiker für Fakten? Es interessieren sich relativ
viele Leute für Fakten, die Hardcore-Verschwörungstheoretiker vielleicht nicht, allerdings sind das ja
Leute, die werden ja nicht als Verschwörungstheoretiker geboren. Es gibt ein paar Leute, die der Meinung
sind, dass Obamas Bodyguard ein Exenmensch ist oder sowas oder dass die Erde flach ist
oder dass Bill Gates uns Mikrochippen will oder sowas, aber es werden auch Leute mit
einer Zeit zu Verschwörungstheoretikern, weil sie überzeugt werden, dass da was dran sein
muss und wenn du auf der anderen Seite die Sachen besser erklärst, nimmst du denen
einen kompletten Wind aus den Segeln. Naja, das vermisse ich so ein bisschen, bei vielen
Sachen, man muss das ordentlich erklären, nur wenn man Sachen ordentlich erklärt, kann
man Leute davon überzeugen. Kobold, oh hör mal auf ey. Alter Kobold, aber wir machen
noch einen Kobold-Stream. Heute ist ja nur aus der Reihe Stream. Eigentlich, ich war
gerade einkaufen, eigentlich hab ich noch ein paar Waffen-Attachments frei, dann hab
ich gesagt, nee ich hab schon 4 Tage nicht mehr gestreamt, ich muss jetzt ne Runde streamen.
Dann geh ich halt wieder, mach was willst. Du musst aber, Moment, Patrick, ich seh gerade,
du musst noch subscriben. So als Obermod, wie geht das ey. Hast du schon was zu Kot gesagt,
ja hab ich. Nein, also Leute, keiner, ich hab grad gesagt, man muss Sachen erklären
und keiner muss subscriben, ich banne niemand, der nicht subscribt. Oh ClocksHD ist da. Oh
bei, vielleicht doch. Und weißt ja nicht. Ja nee, ich sehs doch, du hast doch diesen
First Subscription. Ich glaube, das ist damit dabei irgendwie. Oder auch nicht, ach was
auch immer, ist wurscht. Hast du schon was zu Kot gesagt, ja, dass der Multiplayer scheiße
ist, aber Warzone und 2versus2 ganz gut ist. Der Kommentator, das stimmt nicht, du hast
5 Monate subscribt. Fehlt da nicht noch was? Fehlt da nicht noch was? Geht das nicht noch
weiter? Ich glaub, das ist nur die halbe Copypasta. Oh glaubt mir, ich kenne viele Twitch Copypastas.
Ach Leute, wir müssen übrigens noch was machen. Äh, warte mal. No Happy Meal for
10 Monate, dankeschön. Excellent Subscription. Leute, wir müssen jetzt mal was checken. Mach
den Virgin-Check. Das ist auch so total dämliche Copypasta, die ich letztens gefunden hab. Das
ist richtig dumm, oder? So. Okay, ich wollte mir ja gucken, was gerade auf Github trendet.
Ähm, das haben wir, Java Zeugs, Igitt. Hör mal auf, muss das jetzt sein? Wow, juckt mich
überhaupt nicht. Facebook, IOS, SDK, die machen von nix halt, oder? Was ist das? Super
Mario 64 decompiled. Ach, das kenn ich, das haben wir uns doch schon mal angeguckt. Ich
glaube, die haben es mittlerweile sogar geschafft, dass ein komplettes laufiges Game rauskommt.
Was ist das? A new bootable USB-Solution. Was ist das? Äh, ein USB-Stick? Create bootable
USB-Drive. Hä? Das ist ja so absolut nichts Neues, oder? Da kann man USB-Sticks machen
mit Images drauf. Ja gut, es macht dann einen fertigen USB-Stick mit einem schönen Menü.
Das ist eigentlich ganz nett. Das kann man bestimmt mal brauchen, das speichere ich mir.
Wobei man sagen muss, ich glaube, ich hab schon seit einem Jahr nicht mehr normalen
Rechner oder länger normalen Rechner vom USB-Stick gebootet. Moment, was? Augmented Reality
Copy und Paste. Ah, irgendwelches VR Zeug. Das ist so eine typische JavaScript-Geschichte
wieder. Es gibt ja noch nicht genug Bundler und Minifier für JavaScript. Jetzt gibt es
auch noch einen Go. Das ist eine typische JavaScript-Geschichte. Ich glaube, es vergeht
kein Tag, wo nicht 10 neue, gehypte JavaScript-Libraries rauskommen. Viel Spaß beim Einkaufen, ja. Vielleicht
finden sie irgendwie ein Kobold-Buch. Wobei, ich glaube, im Edeka haben die sowas nicht.
Frag doch mal im Edeka ein Kobold-Buch. Die denken dann, ja, ist das eine Zutat? Irgendwie
was zum Kochen? Ich weiß nicht, wie lange ich da bin. Ich kann es euch nicht sagen.
Ich habe nämlich überhaupt nichts vor hier im Stream, geschweige denn. Irgendwas, ich
habe Lust gesehen. Leute, vier Tage habe ich immer gestreamt. Da wird es mal echt wieder
Zeit. Was sollen denn die Leute hier machen auf Twitch, wenn ich nicht streame? Der Michael
5 Billiarden ist bestimmt schon wieder seit drei Tagen im Chat und denkt sich, wann geht
es denn los? Es gibt eine neue Node-Library, um Chrome zu automatisieren. Warum soll ich
jetzt Chrome nochmal automatisieren? Ach, das ist ein Browser-Automatisierungstool,
was Chrome und Firefox und WebKit automatisiert. Okay, das ist wahrscheinlich nicht schlecht.
Warzone-Onstream kann ich gar nicht, weil... Okay, kann ich doch. Machen wir aber nicht.
E-Mail-Leak. Das ist die gleiche E-Mail, die kennt ihr alle. Die geht auch für Donations
und Subscriptions und alles. Da ist kein Leak. Die steht sogar irgendwo hier in den About,
im Channel irgendwo unter About. Die ist nicht secret. Kein Leak. Chat. Aber wenn ihr wollt,
ist es meinetwegen Leak, wenn ihr euch besser fühlt. Fuck, Alter. Scheiße. E-Mail-Adresse
geleakt. OMG. Donations sind doch aus. Ja, Donations sind aber nur aus, weil der Donation-Link
verbackt war. Übrigens habt ihr mitgekriegt, dass in Overwatch jetzt total viele Pros abspringen,
die keinen Bock mehr auf das Game haben und lieber Valorant spielen. Darklyde drei Monate
abonniert hat. Dankeschön. Massive Subscription. Also Overwatch ist jetzt ziemlich, ziemlich
dead. Ich frag mich, was die in ihrer Leak machen. Die haben ein komplettes Team. Eines
der besten Teams überhaupt. Haben die komplett gekickt in der Overwatch-Leak. Ich weiß nicht,
was da los ist. Diese ganze Overwatch-Leak-Geschichte war von Anfang an kompletter Crap. Kompletter
gestellter Fake-Hype, zusammengeschustert von Leuten, die vom E-Sport keinen Plastenschimmer
haben. Und das zeigt sich jetzt. Und das rächt sich jetzt. Max, du hast dich im Battle.net
Launcher gespielt. Oh fuck, Alter. In der Suppe im Battle.net Launcher, im Fernseh.
Jetzt vorbei. Da ist er. Los geht's mit Warzone-Coaching. Easy. Das ist echt was. Das würde ich sogar
streamen. Muss ich mal gucken, ob ich irgendeinen guten Spieler finde, der mich mal ordentlich
coachen kann in Warzone, dass ich meinen zweieinhalb Monaten Rückstand ein bisschen aufhole mit
Game-Knowledge. Keine bekannten Leute. Die besten Spieler sind eh nicht welche, die
man groß kennt. OWL war doch toll. Vor allem als Parals rauskamen, sie meinten das voll...
Die Overwatch-Maps. Das ist so ein Ding. Leute, mir fällt gerade was ein. Overwatch-Maps sind
scheiße. Modern Warfare-Maps sind scheiße. Und seit ein paar Jahren ist Blizzard und Activision
ganz dicke. Da stimmt doch was nicht. Da kann doch was nicht stimmen. Ich würde sagen,
die sind hier wirklich auf der Spur. BigBrain, ja. Kann man ein Mean-Bot eigentlich ohne weiteres
selbst benutzen? Ne, das ist nicht auf GitHub. Das ist nur eine uralte Version auf GitHub,
aber die funktioniert. Und was hat wohl Bill Gates damit zu tun? Ich glaube, Bill Gates
hat in den Sound-Files der Spiele versteckte Botschaften hinterlassen, die die Leute schon
darauf einstimmen sollen bzw. den Widerstand brechen sollen, unbewusst gegen Chip-Implantate.
Ich glaube, wir sind hier wirklich was großem auf der Spur. So. What? Kannst du eine Twitch-E-Grill-Tierliste
machen? Ne, ich gucke kaum weibliche Streamer. Keine Ahnung, wer die besten oder hottesten
oder was auch immer besten Twitch-Grills sind. Keine Ahnung. Einzige Belegrate, ich glaube,
einzige Streamerin, der ich followe und schon seit Jahren. Ich weiß aber auch ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht, warum ich da angefangen habe zu followen, ist Miramizu, das jemand kennt.
Und ich gucke nicht oft, aber die ist nicht blöd. Also die Leute, die tun immer so nach
dem Motto, alter Mädel, wie du dich hier gibst im Stream und bla bla bla, die tun immer so
oft moralisch, aber rhetorisch outet die teilweise schon ganz schön. So die ganzen Flamer-Spasten
im Chat. Also die ist auf jeden Fall nicht blöd. Oh nein Max, warum? Aber da bin ich
da falsch in der Liste für zu machen. Hat sich schon die IHK gemeldet? Achso, ne, ich
glaube nicht, dass es irgendjemand interessiert bei der IHK. Ja, mache ich nachher, mache
ich nachher. Keck W. Müsstest du dann nicht doppelt das, das ist eine interessante Frage,
da wollte ich letztes Mal was dazu sagen. Ich habe ja mein Netzwerks Setup erklärt
das letzte Mal, so mit Fritzbox für ZIP und VoIP, den Mikrotik Router und davor die Connectbox
von Vodafone. Da hatte jemand gefragt, müsstest du dann nicht doppelt natt machen, wenn auf
der Fritzbox vor dem Mikrotik auch ZIP laufen soll? Ne, muss ich nicht, weil beide hängen
ja an der Connectbox dran, also es ist nicht so, dass mein kompletter Traffic durch die
Fritzbox gehen würde. Was E-Grill oder E-Boil zum, das kann ich nicht aufmachen, je nachdem
was das für eine Seite ist. Das traue ich mich nicht aufzumachen. Heute ein spezielles
Vorhaben, ja das spezielle Vorhaben ist, dass ich nach vier Tagen mal wieder online komme
im Stream. Ansonsten nix. Eigentlich wollte ich heute gar nicht online kommen. Stand Vodafone?
Naja, also die letzten Tage hat es funktioniert. Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass die zweite
Nachricht die ich gekriegt habe, so wie vermutet, wirklich von irgendeinem Social Media Management
Typ gekommen ist, weil die hat sich so überhaupt nicht nach einem Support Mitarbeiter angehört,
die zweite Message. Hab ich euch ja vorgelesen. Ich weiß, ich kann es noch mal vorlesen für
die, die nicht dabei waren. Und wahrscheinlich haben die das jetzt gefixt. Wahrscheinlich
bin ich in irgendeine Liste gerutscht. Größer gleich 10k Follower auf Twitter, auf YouTube
und sonst was, bitte fixen. Weil die erste Nachricht, die ich gekriegt habe, wir haben
hier extra schon eine Liste für Vodafone ausreden. Vodafone ausreden. Erst war die WLAN SSID
doppelt. Modem Werte, schlechte Einstrahlung, Modem Neustarten, es gibt Probleme mit der
Connectbox deutschlandweit, die sind jetzt behoben, Modem Neustarten, Modem Neustarten,
Großraumstörungen im Raum Hanau, Frankfurt. Und danach habe ich die Nachricht gekriegt.
Danach habe ich die Nachricht gekriegt. Einmal vom Support. Hallo, wir sind diesbezüglich
informiert und arbeiten gerade daran, die Störungen zu beheben. Und eine Viertelstunde
später, das war nach dem dritten oder vierten Tag in Folge, wo wir Probleme haben, wo ich
jeden Abend rumgespammt habe auf Twitter, habe ich dann eine Nachricht gekriegt, die
sich so überhaupt gar nicht nach Support liest. Und zwar, vielen Dank für deine Nachricht.
Tut mir leid zu lesen, dass dein Stream beeinträchtigt ist. Leider gibt es da im Moment eine Großstörung
in deinem Anschlussbereich. Die Technik arbeitet mit Hochdruck an der Behebung, das sollte
bald erledigt sein. Bitte hab noch etwas Geduld. Wenn alles wieder läuft, kannst du uns gerne
wieder schreiben, dann können wir uns um eine entsprechende Gutschrift kümmern. Ich wünsche
dir einen schönen Tag, liebe Grüße. Das klingt so null nach den Support-Nachrichten
von vorher. Ich habe so irgendwie die Gefühl, dass das irgendein Social Media Management
Typ ist. Und er hat sich jetzt gedacht, oh fuck, der spammt jetzt jeden Abend, wie scheiße
wir sind. Vielleicht sollten wir das mal fixen. Hast du schon das Drama wegen dem neuen Twitch-Consil
mitbekommen? Ne, ich habe das Drama mitgenommen um die Corona-Warn-App. Da drehen die Leute
wieder ab. Wo ist das denn? Die sind wieder am diskutieren in der Corona-Warn-App. Das
ist also auf dem GitHub-Repo von der deutschen Corona-Warn-App sind sie gerade wieder am
diskutieren, ob es nicht Leute beleidigt, wenn man eher sie und Anrede nicht gendergerecht
verwendet. Das ist natürlich das allergrößte Problem, was man bei einer Corona-Warnung-App
hat. Ob die Gender-Bezeichnungen richtig sind. Logischerweise, was könnte bei so einer Corona-App
sonst wichtig sein? Nicht Warp, Warn. Wie heißt denn das Repo noch mal Leute? Corona-Warn-App
ist das Ding. Auf GitHub, genau. Wo ist der GitHub-Link? Ja. Ich mache mal Achtung Leute,
Augenwarnung. Wenn du hier guckst, was hier Closed ist. Was da wieder diskutiert wird.
Wenn du hier suchst. Geschlechtssensitive Sprache in deutschen Dokumenten. Oh mein Gott,
das ist unglaublich für eine Corona-App. Das geht nicht. Alter, die drehen echt alle
ab. Naja, also immer. Es ist egal. Da habe ich mir gedacht, wenn wir echt keine Probleme
haben bei einer Corona-Warn-App, als dass die gender-korrekte Bezeichnung drin ist,
dann weiß ich auch nicht. Hattest du in deiner 4 HE-Kiste Hardware oder Software-Rate? Wenn
ja, wählst du ZFS-Rate 1. Was hat jemand eben gefragt, ob ich irgendwelches Twitch-Drama
mitbekommen habe? Hast du schon das Drama um den neuen Twitch-Conceal mitbekommen?
Moment, was ist das? Hä? Was soll das sein? Moment.
was hat das jetzt mit Twitch? Was hat das jetzt mit Twitch-Skandal zu tun? Hä?
Wo ist das jetzt? Verstehe ich nicht. Hä? Es gibt Sachen, die verstehe ich nicht. Hä?
Wie ist bei dem neuen Twitch-Safety-Advisor-Conceal? Was ist ein Twitch-Safety-Advisory-Conceal?
Okay. Ich sehe schon, in welche Richtung das führt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich mir das jetzt
geben will. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich dazu im Stream wieder was sagen soll. Okay. Ich ahne
schon, in welche Richtung das geht, aber mal gucken. Wir sind ja aktuell gerade überall
sehr drauf bedacht, dass sich auch ja keiner in irgendeiner Art und Weise mehr gekränkt
fühlt, was im Endeffekt darauf rausläuft, dass noch mehr Leute als vorher, aber halt
vielleicht andere. Also sogar auf Deutsch. Okay. Die Sicherheit und Gesundheit unserer
Community hat für Twitch oberste Priorität. Ist auch schön. Wir freuen uns deshalb heute
die Gründung des Twitch-Sicherheitsbeirats anzukündigen, der in Zukunft das Wachstum
unserer Community unterstützen würde. Also wenn ich an das Thema Sicherheitsbeirat denke,
das Erste, was mir in Sinn kommt, ist sowas wie Account-Sicherheit oder dass man schaut,
dass die Leute nicht so sehr scammen und debaten können mit Short-Uls und solche Geschichten.
Das klingt für mich jetzt erstmal nach Sicherheitsbeirat. So. Der Sicherheitsbeirat wird informieren
und Entscheidungen von Twitch anleiten, indem er seine Erfahrungen und Expertise sowie sein
Glauben an die Mission von Twitch einbringt. Den Satz habe ich nicht verstanden. Was? Der
Sicherheitsbeirat wird informieren und Entscheidungen von Twitch anleiten? Was ist eigentlich hier
mit den Buchstaben los, wenn man die markiert? Indem er seine Erfahrungen und Expertise
sowie sein Glauben an die Mission von Twitch einbringt. Den Satz verstehe ich nicht. Wirklich
low-brain. Ich verstehe den Satz nicht. Ok, machen wir mal weiter. Communities dabei zu
unterstützen, zusammen etwas zu erschaffen. Das ist bestimmt aus dem Englischen übersetzt.
Der Satz leuchtet mir nicht so ganz ein, aber ok. Vielleicht bin ich einfach zu low IQ
dafür. Der Rat wird unter anderem bei vollen Themen beraten. Entwurf neu richtigen und
Aktualisierung bestellen. Das ist doch nicht verkehrt. Also ich meine, inwieweit ihr jetzt
was zu sagen habt, ist mal fraglich. Letztendlich wird Twitch nach wie vor sagen, wir machen
die Sachen so, wie wir sie machen wollen. Aber Leute, ich kann nicht beurteilen, wer
da am Start ist und welche Expertise die Leute haben. Nur mal auch für die Idee gesprochen,
ist das doch eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, so eine Art Gremium aus erfahrenen Streamern
und Leuten zu haben, die sich halt auskennen, was quasi die Twitch-Community so mag und
haben will und dass du sich dann kurz schließt mit Twitch, wenn es um Regeländerungen geht.
Das klingt doch jetzt erstmal gar nicht so blöd. Ich meine, da könnte man zum Beispiel
dann auch mal wirklich den ein oder anderen Kontroversen reinsetzen, der schon öfter
sich mal in die Brennnesseln gesetzt hat, so einen wie XQC zum Beispiel, der schon öftmals
drunter, weiß ich, es war ja oftmals auch zu Recht, aber auch schon ein bisschen drunter
zu leiden hatte, dass manche Sachen sehr schwammig sind. Ich erinnere nur mal an diese ganze
Geschichte mit, wenn man tryhard postet, wäre das racist und sowas. Ich finde, so Sachen
könnte man schon klarer in Richtlinien regeln. Wobei das auch so ein Zusammenspiel aus Overwatch
League und Twitch am Ende gewesen ist. Ich meine, das reine Benutzen eines offiziellen
Emotes, ohne Text, ohne Kontext, was auch immer rein, das benutzt eines Emotes, kann
ja wohl kaum großartig racist sein. Das ist ja nicht umsonst ein offizielles Twitch-Emote.
Wenn jetzt einer hergeht und einen Hakenkreuz in Bella Twitch TV macht, das ist mal wieder
was ganz anderes, aber wir reden ja über offizielle Twitch-Emotes. So, Entwicklung
von Produkten und Funktionen zur Erhöhung von Sicherheit und Moderation. Klingt doch
auch sinnvoll. Förderung, gesunder Streaming und Work-Life-Balance-Gewohnheiten. Schutz
der Interessen von Randgruppen. Das ist halt, wo man sich immer auf dünnem Eis bewegt.
Man muss bei dieser ganzen Sache immer gucken, also ich bin rein für die Sache, bin ich voll
dafür. Man muss allerdings immer gucken, dass es nicht ins komplette Gegenteil umschlägt.
Zum Beispiel, so nach dem Motto, wir sind jetzt alle Feministen, deswegen sind jetzt
auf einmal alle Männer trash. Dann hat man im Prinzip, außer dass man das einmal geflippt
hat, so wer jetzt trash ist und wer jetzt Hate abbekommt, hat man einfach einmal umgedreht.
Das ist ja auch nicht Sinn und Zweck der Sachen. Also Schutz von Interessen von Randgruppen,
klar, immer. Allerdings muss man halt gucken, dass nicht andere komplett ins Abseits dadurch
wieder geraten. Das ist halt, das ist schwierig. Das ist auch so ein Thema, wo man es nie allen
recht machen kann. Okay, also diese Gruppe besteht aus Online-Sicherheitsexperten und
Twitch-Creator. Ich denke bei Sicherheitsexperten, gerade bei Online-Sicherheitsexperten wirklich
an Security. Und ich habe halt das Gefühl jetzt, so wie ich das lese, und bei so was
ist Gefühl immer das Allerwichtigste. Ich habe das Gefühl, den geht es bei Sicherheit
eher so um Safe in Form von, es wird nicht gehated, es wird nicht geflamed, es ist,
wir haben uns alle lieb, wohlfühlen und sowas. Die meinen mit Sicherheit, glaube ich, gar
nicht IT-Security. Safe Spaces, genau wie es das immer auf Englisch nennen. Also diese
Gruppe besteht aus Online-Sicherheitsexperten, richtig, richtig nice Musik, und Twitch-Creator,
die ein tiefer gehendes Verständnis von Twitch, sowie dessen Inhalt und seiner Kombi, das
ist doch gut. Beim Zusammenstellen dieses, ich bin mal gespannt, wer da alles drinne
ist. Beim Zusammenstellen dieses Rates haben wir darauf geachtet, sowohl Experten mit einer
externen Perspektive, als auch Twitch-Streamer mit einem tiefen Verständnis, wozu braucht
man da externe Experten? Das geht doch um Twitch-Content, oder? Man fragt die Leute,
die Twitch-Content machen. Mit einem tiefen Verständnis für die einzigartigen Herausforderungen
und Ansichten eines Creators, bla, bla, bla, bla. Jedes Mitglied dieses Rates, ähm, Moment,
jedes Mitglied dieses wurde sorgfältig ausgeholt, wobei die Vertrautheit mit der Twitch-Community
und der relevante persönliche und berufliche Erfahrungsschatz berücksichtigt wurde. Wir
freuen uns sehr, mit dieser talentierten Gruppe zusammenzuarbeiten und besten Ort für
Aufbau und halt eine Community zu machen. Die Gründung des Sicherheitsbeirats ist nur
einer der Maßnahmen, die wir im Namen von Vertrauen und Sicherheit vornehmen. Wir investieren
weiterhin in... Okay, wer ist da dabei? Kenn ich nicht. Keine Ahnung, wer das ist. Äh,
den kenn ich. Den kenn ich, da hab ich sogar ein paar Streams geguckt, aber zu wenig, dass
ich da irgendwas drüber aussagen könnte. Kenn ich nicht. Kenn ich auch nicht. Ah, das
ist, wo wir das Video eben gesehen haben. Kenn ich auch nicht. Keine Ahnung. Kenn ich
auch nicht. Kenn ich auch nicht. Den kenn ich! Das ist ein Path of Exile-Streamer. Den guck
ich gerne. Okay. Okay, halt mal fest, ich kenne, ich kenne zwei Leute. Das heißt jetzt
nix, mir nur aufgefallen. So, ich kenne, ich kenne, ich kenne zwei Leute, ähm, aus der,
aus der Liste. Ähm, gut, zu sagen, haben sie natürlich nix, letztendlich. Aber, mal
ganz ehrlich, wie war es denn bisher auf Twitch? Oder wie ist es denn, wie ist es denn auf
allen, ich sag mal auf nahezu, auf allen mir bekannten Plattformen wie Twitch oder YouTube
oder was haben wir denn da sonst noch, äh, Facebook, Gaming, keine Ahnung, Mixer, was
es nicht alles gibt, ja. Es ist doch auf allen so, dass du letztendlich als Creator auf gedeih
und verderbender Plattform ausgeliefert bist. So, und das Twitch jetzt nicht sagt, wir nehmen
da irgendeinen Beirat an sieben schwierigen Leuten, die dann auch noch quasi ein festes
Veto-Recht haben, kann ich verstehen. Ist doch, äh, das wäre doch aus Sicht von Twitch überhaupt
nicht, überhaupt nicht anzustreben. So, und natürlich nimmt man sich jetzt auch Leute,
die, äh, mit denen man wohl gut auskommt. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wo, wo genau ist
denn jetzt der Shitstorm bei der ganzen Geschichte, den verstehe ich doch nicht so genau. Hast
du schon mitbekommen, dass Facebook Giphy gekauft hat? Nee. Also ich verstehe, also wo, wo genau
ist, warum, wo ist da jetzt denn jetzt der Beef? Ich glaube, die Leute sind wegen dieser Transgender-Personen
mad, warum? Die haben sie doch nicht mehr alle. Man darf auf alle Leute sauer sein. Ja, das
ist okay berechtigt, wenn sie irgendwas gesagt haben, was einen anpisst, äh, was einen anpisst,
kann man sauer sein. Aber ich meine nur, weil er, oder sie, weiß nicht, wie, wie man sie
eher ihn jetzt richtig nennt, weil das ist ja schmierig, deswegen sag ich jetzt mal sie,
ähm, und nur weil sie, keine Ahnung, bunte Haare hat, warum sollte man auf jemanden sauer
sein? Es ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Die können echt alle machen, was sie wollen und
wenn einer heute sagt, er wäre gerne nen Fahrrad, kann er das meinetwegen machen. Man sollte
nur nicht davon ausgehen, dass es auf jeden Fall die restliche Welt dann sofort versteht,
aber ansonsten, ey, jeder, jeder, jeder, jeder will. Ähm, also warum man sich jetzt da drüber
aufregt? Okay, warte mal, Reddit, Twitch, worüber regen sich denn jetzt auf? Gar nicht,
oder? Oh, oh, das ist schlecht. Die dürfen IRC nicht entfernen. Das ist viel schlimmer.
Die dürfen IRC nicht entfernen. Dann geht mein Chatlogger nicht mehr, wenn die IRC entfernen.
Mein Chatlogger basiert auf der, dass der Twitch Chat über IRC erreichbar ist. Achso,
okay, sie entfernen paar IRC Features, das müsste immer noch funktionieren. Wieso benutzt
du nicht BRC, wenn die IRC entfernen? Excellent. Warum man jetzt da dran rumdoktern muss, verstehe
ich allerdings trotzdem nicht. Also ich sehe hier ehrlich gesagt kein Geflame über den
Sicherheitsrat. Okay, anscheinend das hier. Nee, nee, ich will mich damit gar nicht weiter
beschäftigen. Es ist wie auf YouTube, eigentlich ist mir scheißegal, was die Plattform macht.
Ich stelle hier meinen Content zur Verfügung im Endeffekt, weil ich hier die Leute am besten
erreichen kann und wir haben ja auch hier den besten, der besten, Moment, aber ansonsten
ist mir das vollkommen egal, was die Plattform macht. Wenn ihr nicht gerade komplett geisteskranke
Dinge beschließen, sodass ich keinen Bock mehr drauf habe, hier zu streamen, ist mir
das ziemlich egal. Du musst erstmal die Basics machen, ja. Wie spricht man es richtig aus?
Basics, ich kann das nicht aussprechen. Wie spricht man Basics richtig aus? Die Basics.
Du musst mal die Basics machen. Basics, ne? Musst die Basics. Ist das Schwäbisch? Das
ist bestimmt Schwäbisch. Schwäbisch ist hessisch, das ist doch nicht hessisch. Das ist nicht
hessisch. Also ich weiß, wie sich hessisch anhört, aber die Basics sagt hier keiner.
Was sagt keiner hier, die Basics? Stuttgarter Dialekt, ja das ist Schwäbisch, ja. Wie findest
du San Diego Spongebos? Keine Ahnung. Ich kenne mich im deutschen Hip-Hop-Segment nicht
aus. Aber ich kann was zum schwedischen Dialekt sagen. Auf die Gefahr hin, dass jetzt ein
paar Leute schenkig sind, aber ich muss euch auch erklären warum. Ich mag schwäbischen
Dialekt nicht. Das liegt daran, weil mein erster Arbeitgeber, der Provider, wo ich meine
Ausbildung gemacht habe, die kam aus Ulm und die haben alle Schwäbisch geredet und
das war ein echt komischer Laden. Also ich habe nichts gegen Schwaben, aber immer wenn
ich einen Schwäbisch reden höre, dann muss ich daran denken. Ja, wenn dich fragt, sag
einfach Beste. Ich sag selten Beste zu was, was ich gar nicht kenne. Weil im Zweifelsfall
ist es nicht Beste, sondern zack. Oh ne, ne Korok das kenne ich noch. Oh nein, das kenne
ich noch. Das ist das Zwischenshow, die immer im ersten Programm läuft. In Hessen laufen
im zweiten sind Mainzelmännchen, im ersten ist Onkel Otto und im Schwäbischen ist es
dieser Affe und der Esel im Fernsehprogramm. Das kann ich mich daran erinnern. Ich war
ja manchmal über Nacht dort in Ulm und da habe ich auch ein bisschen Fernsehen geguckt
und da kamen diese komischen Zwischeneinspieler mit dem Esel und dem Affe immer. Das hier,
das hier. Da denke ich mit Horror dran. Das erinnert mich an Zeiten wo ich mich nicht
gerne dran erinnere. Ansonsten muss ich sagen, wo wir gerade bei Dialekten sind, es gab ja
mal eine Abstimmung, dass ich glaube sächsisch oder so, wäre der unsexiest Dialekt oder
der dummste Dialekt oder so. Ich muss ja sagen, dass ich irgendwo sächsisch noch ganz gut
finde. Vielleicht weil ich den Fabian und den Karsten kenne, aber die reden ja beide
nicht so richtig krass sächsisch. Da habe ich keine Schmerzen mit. Also das ist der einzige
Dialekt der mir wirklich auf den Keks geht, ist schwemisch. Und eben weil ich da persönliche
Erfahrung mit habe. Ansonsten ist mir das eigentlich vollkommen wurscht, ob es jetzt
einer bayerisch labert, sächsisch, irgendwie norddeutsches Zeug oder sonst wie. Was ich
geil finde, also eine Sache die mir aufgefallen ist an sächsisch, ich war ja auch schon drei
viermal oder so in Dresden, dass im Osten sagen total viele Leute immer Nü, so wie
wir hier sagen ach oder hä oder was sagen die Nü. Aber so langgezogen, so Nü. Ich kann
es nicht nachmachen, Nü, Nü, Nü. Ich kann es nicht nachmachen, aber ihr wisst wahrscheinlich
was ich meine. In Hessen sagt man Hä. Hä geht für alles. Nü gibt es nur in Dresden,
sonst nirgends. Ok. Ja. So genau kenne ich mich da nicht aus. So gibt es ja noch ein
paar sinnvolle Fragen. Max kannst du mir sagen was W-Pad ist? W-Pad das hört sich an wie
wenn man Leerzeichen auffüllt, aber ich glaube nicht, dass das damit gemeint ist. Man paddet
Leerzeichen, Whitespaces oder so. Keine Ahnung. Was hältst du denn von Deno bisher? Wie gesagt
ich habe mir ein paar Webcasts dazu angeguckt. Ich sehe die Vorteile gegenüber Node.js, allerdings
was ich nicht verstehe ist warum man das verwenden sollte. Das wichtigste in einem ganzen Ökosystem
von Node.js ist doch dass es so viele Pakete gibt und die gibt es für Deno nicht. Voice
Chat abgeschafft weil es diskriminierend ist. Da der blödsinn ausfasst. Mittlerweile
sind es so viele Leute im Chat, dass du die
witzigen Situationen von einem Pipega-Chat hast wie früher. Früher hast du irgendwas
total hirnverbranntes gepostet und da haben die Leute noch darauf reagiert im Chat oder
umgedreht. Du hast auf was dummes reagiert was Leute im Chat geschrieben haben aber das
geht mittlerweile nicht mehr. Mittlerweile spammen die Leute einfach nur 150 Zeichen
Emotes am Stück oder machen Donations. Wer es kennt weiß was ich meine. Total hängengeblieben.
Deswegen kann ich mir das nicht mehr angucken. Ansonsten muss man sagen XQC hat schon Twitch
ganz schön seinen Stempel aufgedrückt. Also viele Sprüche und viele Ausdrücke ist quasi
mittlerweile fast gang und gäbe auf Twitch. Z.B. Go a Garn. A Garnel. TriHead7, ja jetzt
auch sowas. Genau. Wie gehts dem Fabian? Dem gehts gut. Der spielt Mobile Games. Du hast
dir erwähnt, dass du bei einer Bank arbeitest. Kennst du Star Money? Ja, kenne ich. Haben
wir aber nicht. Das ist doch eher was wo man daheim sein Rechnungswesen Zeug machen kann.
Wann kommt der Staubsauger Minecraft Let's Play? Das funktioniert nicht so richtig. Gibt
keine grafische Ausgabe auf dem Ding. Auch nicht über SSH. Das läuft nicht. Wenn der
Friseur Mobile Games spielt kann es ihm nicht gut gehen. Doch tatsächlich. Der findet das
super. Ich weiß auch nicht was da los ist. Hast du schon die neue Tech Demo von der neuen
Unreal Engine angesehen? Nö. Es gibt eine neue Unreal Engine. Echt? Unreal Engine 5
Demo. Ok, gucken wir uns mal an. Die neue Tech Demo ist geisteskrank. Ach, Badri, du
bist ja noch da. Huge Poggers. Leute, ich hab ein Problem. Ich muss mal aufs Klo. Was
macht man da? Ich mach euch den Pepega Song an. Ihr dürft euch jetzt das Aquarium und
den Zug angucken und ich mach 5 Minuten Pause und geh aufs Klo. Aber das allerwichtigste
Chat. Dass ihr nicht irgendwie auf die Idee kommt, jetzt während ich weg bin, XQC Chat
2.0 zu machen. Außer Anygifters im Chat. Die dürfen natürlich. Geh ich jetzt auf
mein Handy und mach mein Chat auf. Ich sehe euch. Ich sehe euch. Sonst bin ich in 5 Minuten
wieder da. Ich mach vielleicht noch mal kurz ein Overlay. Text. Kurz auf Klo. Perfekt.
So, ich bin gleich wieder da. Gleich wieder am Start. Oder wie man jetzt sagen würde,
der Bruder muss groß.
So, Chat. Ich hab alles gesehen. Jetzt werd ich erstmal 20 Leute bannen. Okay, also Unreal
5 Tech Reveal. Unreal Engine 5 Revealed. Bekommst du viele Nudes von Fans geschenkt? Ich kann
mich vor Dickpicks kaum noch retten. AvgText. Mal gucken ob unsere Bandbreite richtig eingestellt
ist. Ja, sehr gut. Die Musik soll ich vielleicht mal ausmachen. Nix League. Der Chat. So einfach
kann ich nicht gebadet werden. Es ist weder IP League noch StreamKey League. Okay. Unreal
Engine 5 Revealed. Schauen wir uns das doch mal an. Bisschen lauter, hm? Oh, oui, oui.
Oh. Kap. Oh, Zeitschirr. Sitzen die nicht viel zu nahe? Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Sitzen die nicht viel zu nahe beieinander? Und ganz ohne Maske? Oh, ZBrush. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Okay. Das ist interessant. Was es auf einer PS5 läuft. Auf der anderen Seite, wenn man
sich die Specks angeguckt hat, da geht es bei mir wenigstens ein bisschen vorwärts wieder
mit Hardware in Konsolen. Ist nicht mehr so enttäuschend wie bei der Xbox One und bei
der PS4 zur Release. Okay. Ich mache auch mal die unten mal die Leiste weg. Ist das
Partner 2? Oh, die Beleuchtung sieht schon geil aus. Das sieht, das sieht schon wirklich,
wirklich gut aus. Also, das sieht wirklich gut aus. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja. Ja.
Das sieht wirklich gut aus. Guckt euch das mal an. Ich meine, guckt mal. Denkt euch
mal die Overlays weg. Ja. Denkt euch mal die Overlays weg. Und sowas. Also, das hier könnte
ohne Probleme. Okay. Wenn man sich das Gras anguckt und es pixelt und so. Ja. Okay. Wenn
jemand zu einem sagen würde, sag mir mal, ob das Foto echt ist oder 3D gerendert, dann
würdest du sagen, ja, okay, vielleicht 3D gerendert. Aber wenn dir das Foto einer Kontext
los zeigen würde. Also, ich glaube nicht, dass es direkt einem ins Auge springen würde.
Na, das Gras erkennt man schon. Aber mal angenommen, mal angenommen, es würde euch
eine Landschaftsaufnahme zeigen und da würde das dazwischen liegen. Also, das sieht schon
ganz gut aus. Was? Der Stream pixelt echt jetzt? Allzu viel sollte da eigentlich gar
nicht mal pixeln. Aber okay, wahrscheinlich halt das übliche. Es könnte, na gut, die
Kompression ist natürlich ein bisschen schlechter. Die sieht hier auf YouTube schon besser aus,
stimmt. Was ich cool fände, ein FPS-Counter. Ach, Chat, ich glaube euch kein Wort. Boah,
gut face. Okay. Wisst ihr woran mich das erinnert? Hat irgendjemand dieses Unlimited-Detail-Video
gesehen vor ein paar Jahren? Kennt das noch jemand? Unlimited-Detail, wo bis heute nichts
rausgekommen ist? 16 times the details, genau. Oh man. Chat, meine Güte, wie ich hier mit
mich ist da nix aus. Zumal ich höre es ja selbst, ich spiele mich ja selbst wieder ein.
Der Chat ist heute hart am Dauer debaten. Echtzeit, okay.
Also die Belichtung sieht wirklich extrem gut aus. Ich weiß das wahrscheinlich gar nicht
richtig zu schätzen, aber es sieht wirklich sehr nice aus. Ist wirklich schon mal jemand
so gesprungen? Das frage ich mich bei. Ich weiß, hat mit der Grafik überhaupt nichts
zu tun, ja. Das ist genauso wie in Uncharted. Fünf Meter gesprungen, hingehauen und dann
an einem Arm da gehauen und sich gedacht easy, easy as fuck. Ich hänge hier an einem Arm
rum. Ich gucke jetzt erstmal kurz entspannt nach unten und dann mache ich bam, hochziehen.
Gar kein Problem. Als wird hier durchgestalzt, hä?
Jetzt muss ich mir nochmal angucken. Wie sieht denn das Licht auf der Haut aus beim Durchlaufen?
Das sieht ziemlich gut aus. Das sieht ziemlich gut aus. Ich mein, das sieht, das sieht wirklich
sehr nah an dem aus, wie ich mir das vorstellen würde, wie es halt aussieht.
Ich hab ne Vorschau. Am Wasser habe ich jetzt nicht so viel erkannt. Das Wasser sah eher
so aus, als haben sie drauf, passt nicht so 100% zur Animation. Aber Wasser ist doch
heute schon ziemlich real. Was? Das ist doch nicht anstrengend. Vor allem,
woran kehrtet sie denn? Bitte schön. Das ist cool, dass sowas dabei ist. Da kann quasi
jetzt auch jeder dahergelaufene Typ nen Assassin's Creed Asset Flip machen.
PC Lustig sagt, aber was davon dann wirklich in Games ankommt, das ist doch bei Unreal
bisher immer ziemlich gut. Alles auch in Games angekommen. Wenn man sich die Unreal Demos
anguckt, 3, 4, 5. Ich überleg grad, was waren die Unreal Demo 4? An die 3 kann ich mich
erinnern. Das war dieser Samarita. Der Typ, der die Leute rumboxt. Was war denn der Unreal
4 Trailer nochmal? War doch dieses Zimmer. Wir gucken uns danach nochmal den Unreal 4
Trailer an. Ich kann mich an den Unreal 4 Trailer nicht mehr erinnern. Ich kann mich
doch an den Unreal 3 Trailer erinnern. Wow, ein Michael-5-Spieler an. Ah, habt ihr gesehen,
wie es glänzt? Das ist cool.
Und was haben die von der Hardware drinnen? Ach nee, es ist ja PS5, haben sie ja gesagt.
Normaler PS5.
Das ist alles AMD, ja.
Ich denke mal, das sind eher 30 FPS. Ich glaube nicht, dass das mit 60 läuft. Es ist
auch nicht wirklich zu erkennen, weil das Video halt selbst nur mit 30 ist. Was für
eine Grafikkarte ist vergleichbar mit einer PS5? Oh, ich habe es immer richtig im Kopf.
Ich glaube, eine 2070 oder so, ne? So um den Dreh um eine 2070, glaube, war das. Kann
auch sein, dass ich jetzt komplett falsch liege. Ich kriege es auch im Kopf nicht mehr richtig
zusammen. Portal 3, confirmed. Ezio-Style, nee, doch nicht. Eher, eher. Alles klar. Anthem,
eher Anthem-Style. Ach, das ist das Anthem, wie Mastern, wo sie alle vorgehen. Und durch
Portal und Schnitt, nee, doch nicht. Wieso ist sie nicht einfach vorher hochgeflogen,
sagt Maurice? Naja, weil sie da noch nicht das Level Up hatte, was sie erst oben gekriegt
hat. Dieses, dieses Kletzerding. Ultranice. Ultranice. Wie gesagt, ich bin, ich kenne
mich mit 3D-Programmierzeug und Grafik null aus. Ich habe da nur Absolut-Basic. Das Einzige,
was ich bisher mal OpenGL wirklich from scratch, raw-mäßig programmiert habe, ist die T-Kanne.
Die T-Kanne mit OpenGL. Die Basic-T-Kanne. Das sind ungefähr so 50 Zeilen oder so. Die
OpenGL-T-Kanne ist das Einzige, was ich hier programmiert habe. So richtig low-level 3D.
Und was ist mit Lull-3D? Äh, das, genau, das ist die Annual-4-Demo. Richtig, richtig,
richtig. Ich erinnere mich, das ist, ja, genau, dieses, dieses Flammending. Ja. Moment.
Jetzt brauchen wir eine höhere Auflösung. What? Ah. Und denkt dran, es ist 7 Jahre her,
was wir jetzt sehen. 7 Jahre. Stimmt, ja, jetzt kann ich mich wieder an die Annual-4-Demo
erinnern. Klettert da jetzt nicht auch gleich jemand? Ne, das war wieder was anderes. Das
ist der Typ auf dem Thron, genau. Na, 7 Jahre ist ja heutzutage Hardware-technisch nicht
mehr das, wie es vor, wie 7 Jahre vor 7 Jahren war. Also, es hat sich schon einiges getan,
das sind 7 Jahre, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, wie die 7 Jahre davor. Aber man erkennt
das schon. Patrick, das ist doch wurscht, selbst, selbst wenn sich das, wenn sich das
weiterentwickelt auf den CPUs. Du kannst heute ohne Probleme noch mit einem Rechner, der
4-5 Jahre alt ist, halbwegs spielen und probier das die 7 Jahre davor mal aus. Fand die 5er
auch besser aus Big Brain Chat heute wieder am Start. Wollen wir uns noch die 3er angucken
dann? Da hat sich noch mehr getan. Und ich sag euch Leute, ihr findet wahrscheinlich
die 5er auch besser als die 3er, aber der 3er Trailer ist der beste. Ah, damals hat
man richtig gesagt, boah, die ganzen Partikel und sonst was. Ah, da hat sich schon einiges
getan. Das ist für die PS4. Aber der Trailer ist für alle gleich. Oh, ein KS. So, aber
der 3er Trailer ist der beste. Ich mein, das ist ein Riesenunterschied, wie es aussieht,
ja. Aber der Trailer von der Unreal 3 Engine war am besten bisher. Mal gucken, ob wir das
in ordentlicher Auflösung irgendwie finden. Ja. Ist der beste Trailer, finde ich, von
dem wir sehen. Denkt dran, das sind die Games, also Unreal 3 war ja auf PS3 und Xbox 360,
die Engine schlechthin, ne, da war ja irgendwie gefühlt 60% der Games war Unreal 3. Wobei
das hier garantiert nicht auf der Xbox gelaufen ist. Äh, Unreal 3 kam, was weiß ich, vor
10 Jahren oder so. Aber der Trailer ist am besten. Was auch immer er da macht.
Warum auch immer er an der Kette geschweißt hat.
Wieso da?
Bam in your face
Ah
Sie sind in der Nähe.
das 5 echtes gameplay ist ist cool ja das stimmt also rein aber von der von der von
der aufmachung her wie das geschnitten ist wie das gemacht hat finde ich den 3er immer
noch am besten holy shit was war das denn unreal 1 unreal engine 1 ich glaube das ist auch das
erste mal dass man so wirklich den engine trailer hatte den gameplay engine trailers
ansonsten haben die halt immer einen trailer gemacht in form von halt so einem filmchen
was angeblich halt in echtzeit gelaufen ist hast du die unreal demo oft ja haben wir uns
gerade angeguckt moment was es gibt es gibt telekom unterwäsche kam ist das safe aufzumachen
ja was jetzt was das wenn ich das häkchen weg mache ist das häkchen immer noch da
gebadet grüßes mann scam scam ja ist mir doch vollkommen egal weiter love magenta connected
underwear oh mann for men for women for for kids ok jetzt jetzt wirds aber jetzt wirds
aber gefährlich telekom ja love magenta connected andere entwickelt intelligente
unterwäsche die das smartphone vorüber gehen zum schweigen bringen ok das heißt wenn sich
zwei leute die diese unterwäsche tragen nähern oder was und dann dann schaltet das smartphone
ab bluetooth funktion das habe ich schon mal gesehen das haben uns doch schon mal angeguckt
kann man auf der seite htps zertifikate verschenken krelax ich habe keine ahnung was du meinst
also was bekommt man eine love magenta stofftasche mit kordelzug aha mit magenta dna hoffe ich
unterhosen herren boxershorts ein damenslip hüftige passform zwei love chips was ein
schwachsinn auf lager ich hätte mich auch gewundert wenn das ausverkauft wäre max will
nur den damenslip richtig das war ich da wieder typ auf dem einen foto als corona maske oder
als als atemschutzmaske verwendet haben wir tatsächlich dem kumpel zum geburtstag geschenkt
sagt der blobs rusher exzellent wie gehts tscheko ja was die gerade treibt weiß ich aber der
gehts gut tscheko gehts gut tscheko glaube mit k zumindest guckt sie kritisch auf dem
foto ja was es nicht alles gibt telekom unterwäsche interessant ja aber geguckt
dass man mikro angeblich aus ist das hatten wir schon wünschst du dir das mehr arbeitgeber
nach der krise auf dem zu bleiben mit home office das ist eine sehr gute frage ich glaube
dass das passieren wird ja es ist vollkommen egal ob ich mir das wünsche oder nicht ich
gehe davon aus dass das passieren wird ich gehe ich von aus ja zumal ja auch viele unternehmen
jetzt erst angefangen haben quasi digitale infrastruktur zur bereit bereit zu stellen
dass es überhaupt möglich ist der chat wieder lowbrane chat gerade ja aber es wäre auf jeden
fall cool wenn sich das mehr durchsetzt also wie gesagt ich gehe da fest von aus zumal
es ja auch noch eine weile dauern wird bis das so wieder alles falls überhaupt das mal
jeweils wieder normal wird keine prime subs chat bleibt dumm sieht heute wirklich so aus
ja heute ist heute ist mal abwechslungsweise kein high IQ chat da heute ist wirklich ich
hab ich hab noch nicht mal ich hab noch nicht mal ein emote dafür weil normalerweise ist
der chat der chat ist normalerweise immer schon ziemlich big brain aber heute weiß ich nicht
was mit dem chat los ist david 3 sagt bei mir bleibt home office solange bis der mindestabstand
nicht mehr benötigt wird bei uns ist auch noch home office angesagt liegt an 5g oh stimmt
5g ausbau geht ja immer weiter und all bill gates 5g und bill gates bestimmt für meinen
twitch chat verantwortlich gehe ich auch von aus ich hatte ja schon immer den eindruck
dass mit dem chat was nicht stimmt ok der flur ist nicht mal 1,5 meter breit also bei
uns auf der arbeit ist jetzt so wir kriegen masken gestellt von der firma wir haben allerdings
unsere masken erst eine woche später bekommen als gedacht weil das jetzt kein witz weil
es normale masken nicht getan haben wir mussten uns erst masken mit unserem firmen logo drauf
drucken lassen weil immer das heißt wir haben jetzt quasi paar kisten mit masken wo das
firmen logo drauf ist ganz wichtig man braucht unbedingt atemschutzmasken mit firmen logo
wenigstens ffp 2 fragt kein schimmer also wir wer ins büro geht da kriegt eine maske
gestellt und bei uns ist pflicht dass man die maske an hat sobald man seinen arbeitsplatz
bzw das büro verlässt also sprich wenn man auf den flur geht aufs klo in die kirche
sonst muss die maske anziehen und wer mittagessen will der muss sich vorher anmelden und sagen
wann er kommt und dann kann es sich entweder unten hinsetzen oder ihm mitnehmen oder michael
50 billionen fragt was ich stehe vor einer schwierigen entscheidung also ich habe zwei
angebote für eine ausbildung erstens fachkraft für lagerlogistik aber bekomme im ersten
ausbildung ist ja schon knapp ein k muss aber tatsächlich arbeiten das soll als azubi durchaus
vorkommen ja fachinformatiker für andere für anwendungsentwicklung aber da bekomme
ich im ersten jahr das was gefällt dir denn vom inhalt her besser scheiß mal auf das geld
du kommst mit beidem gehalt nicht über die runden was sagt dir denn mehr zu aber generell
nicht so nice da bin ich ganz bei dir ja aber die meisten leute werden wahrscheinlich nicht
drumherum kommen was gefällt dir denn besser scheiß auf das geld also du kommst mit einem
k im prinzip genauso weit wie mit 600 nehme ich gar nicht chill seit einem jahr zu hause
warum sollte ich arbeiten ja dann mach doch nix dann bleib einfach weiter daheim
als fahrinforter immer nach der ausbildung mehr verdienen als
als fachkraft für lagerlogistik ich habe ehrlich gesagt keine ahnung ich würde aber von ausgehen
ich habe ein manjaru analog zu deinem einrichtung setup meine status leisten sie das gucke ich
mir garantiert nicht im stream an das gucke ich mir erst mal auf der anderen seite an
du hast den image font nicht installiert ja du hast den image font nicht installiert du
musst dir dann immer in meinem fall ist es ein emoji font du musst dir den emoji font
installieren emoji von oder sowas du musst den image font installieren joy pixels joy
pixels muss den zählen geht dann geht deine leiste woher kommt der schlechte ruf von java
da muss ich dich jetzt muss ich dich aber fragen meinst du woher der schlechte ruf kommt warum
ich immer über java lästere oder meinst oder hast du das gehört irgendwo also warum
ich über java lästere hat eigentlich keinen tieferen grund außer dass ich gerne über
java lästere ich kann das es liegt nicht daran dass java irgendwie unbenutzbar und total
scheiße wäre java ist ganz okay man kann schon sachen in java machen ansonsten kommt
daher dass halt früher viele scheiß java programme gab auch noch aus zeiten wo es java
applets gab falls ich noch irgendeiner über an an java applets erinnern kann an anwendungen
die halt ewig laden scheiße aussehen und irgendwie sich einfach crappy anfühlen aber
man darf nicht vergessen dass gerade im finanzsektor die meisten backends in java sind also sprich
wenn ihr auf die seite von eurer bank geht ist die chance dass das da java im hintergrund
läuft relativ hoch also man kann mit java ohne probleme gescheite sachen machen und
außerdem muss man das trennen man muss java die programmiersprache trennen von der runtime
an sich weil die java runtime wenn man eine ordentliche sprache nimmt ist sicherlich ganz
gut ich weiß nicht wieso der direkte vergleich aussehen würde jvm versus dotnet core keine
ahnung dafür mache ich zu wenig mit java aber ich denke mal so viel schlechter oder
besser wie auch immer wird wenn er beide seiten während beide seiten werden sich wahrscheinlich
nicht viel nicht viel nehmen alte hp switches mit java applets sind das schlimmste ja mein
management interface hier auf der serverkiste ist noch in java applets ganz abartig warum
java wäre z plus plus nicht leistungsfähiger ja doch wäre es schöner wäre es nicht also
wenn wenn was noch hässlicher als java ist dann ist es z plus plus aber du findest einfach
deutlich mehr programmierer die verstehen oder zumindest nicht so viel scheiße bauen
können für java als für z plus plus und wenn die komplexität steigt würde ich sagen
hat java trotzdem noch einen vorteil gegenüber z plus plus gerade im bereich wenn es sicher
sein soll oder zumindest schwerer zu exploiten wenn es um finanzgeschichten geht also du
kannst ja quasi in java keine overflows im eigentlichen sinne produzieren in z plus plus
ist das easy aber ich denke weil der größte faktor ist dass im java im finanzsektor etabliert
ist und dass du halt recht einfach java programmierer findest wohingegen fähige z plus plus programmierer
ist deutlich schwieriger bist du aus dem perlzeit alter nein später perlzeit alter
war war noch ein bisschen vor mir man sagt auch die einzige right only sprache
so gut easy money easy life
bei mir ist es ja so ich kriege ich gehe vier tage die wochenwoche arbeiten also ich
verdiene da ganz gut wir haben es letztes mal angeguckt ich sehe dass ich da im geld schwimme
von oder so aber das ist schon ganz ok dazu kommt noch ein bisschen youtube bisschen reflink
bisschen twitch und nachdem ich halt auch jemand bin der kaum geld ausgibt wird es
auch gerade nur mehr aber man weiß nie wofür man es braucht also ich mache das gegenteil
davon ich kaufe mir einfach immer wenn ich was haben will kaufe ich es mir ansonsten
gebe ich kaum geld aus hast du den bachelor gemacht nee so das hat auf fack jetzt habe
ich was gelöscht was denn hast du große ziele im leben ja ich will mal mehr abos auf youtube
ich will mal 300.000 abos auf youtube schaffen dazu müsste ich aber videos machen fährst
so gerne den urlaub ich bin früher gerne in urlaub gefahren bin auch früher relativ
viel geflogen den urlaub aber ich glaube die letzten zehn jahre oder so schon war ich
bis auf ein paar kleinere ausflüge nicht mehr lange weg fliegen in 2020 ja ich meine nicht
gerade jetzt wäre die ganze corona geschichten keine ahnung kann sein kann sein dass wir
damit auch werben aber die ganzen werbesprüche kannst du eh vergessen ich meine was soll
das denn heißen 100 virenscanner 150 firewalls was was soll uns das überhaupt sagen ergibt
überhaupt keinen sinn ja knäher mehr kann man kann man machen weiß aber nicht ob das
gerade so die gute idee ist das ist halt so typisch typischer marketing bullshit circa
100 virenscanner 150 firewalls also ich bezweifle dass es 100 virenscanner irgendwie sicherer
machen als nur nur dann voll und wenn der traffic wirklich durch 150 firewalls durch
muss dann frage ich mich was sie für eine architektur haben
ich habe nicht gesagt dass ich mehr videos mache ich habe gesagt ich verspreche erst
gar nicht dass ich mehr videos mache keine prime subs chat bleibt um mehr low brain chat
heute any primers der blobsrascher schreibt habe heute meinen ersten richtigen job bekommen
danke dafür das ist schön wenn das falls ich damit was zu tun habe wahrscheinlich
liegt erst einmal hauptsächlich an dir dass du die überzeugt hast habe mich damals von
deinen videos inspirieren lassen was mit informatik zu machen sobald erstes galt kommt gibt's
spende ganz paar subs giften excellent dann ist das ist das chat auch nicht so low brain
dann ist endlich wieder high iq chat angesagt oh jack 690 zehn monate in folge massive subscription
es geht es geht auf wer chat ich glaube der chat muss nicht dumm ins bett gehen heute
abend
wie high iq bin ich du bist erst ein monat abonnent du bist noch ganz ganz du bist noch
nicht high iq das kommt noch das das braucht seine zeit aber du musst dabei bleiben sonst
wird das nie was also chat also also wenn die subscription monate iq werden dann werden
wir alle auf dem stand von irgendeinem nordsee krebs das geht ja nicht über zwölf monate
vorbei geht ja nicht über zwölf monate drüber oder zehn monate zehn monate glaube
das ist das ist wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal so nordsee krebs was ist das für ein
sorgen ist es luigi's luigi's menschen nee es soll super mario du wirst nicht gehasst
vom chat der chat kann sowas gar nicht das ist support auf oder kundensupport auf oder
vorniveau selbst alle beauty youtuber auf youtube zusammen haben ja warum streamst du
eigentlich in 48 fps ja die fragen kommt öfters das liegt einfach daran weil 48 fps flüssiger
sind als 30 allerdings fürs einzelne bild mehr von der bitrate übrig bleibt wie bei
60 das sieht besser aus und flüssiger ist quasi das beste aus beiden welten flüssiger
und besser
was schreibt er hier ich regel mich täglich über die leute auf die nicht am ball bleiben
die sind dann meistens auch noch sehr laut oh ja da gibt es viele von die würden am
liebsten noch mit dotnet 3.5 entwickeln mit noch nicht immer vier sondern wenn schon
35 und dort net core ist böse weil neu ja hast du in allen bereichen jetzt mal unabhängig
von dort net bei uns gibt es auch leute wo ich mich frage ob die die letzten die letzten
fünf jahre irgendwie geschlafen haben zum beispiel noch nicht mal erklären können
was oder grob der unterschied ist zwischen dem container oder vm oder man ist experte
für email systeme aber kriegt kein smtb richtig konfiguriert oder was haben wir haben so viele
wir haben so viele experten in anführungsstriche das ist ja so ein thema wenn ich damit anfangen
höre ich gar nicht mehr auf wir haben so viele experten wo ich mich frage in was die experte
sind allerdings höchstwahrscheinlich nicht in dem wofür man sie eingekauft hat
captain peng schreibt ich habe jetzt gar nicht in chat geguckt ich habe die ganze zeit
nur mein tool geguckt schreibt ich studiere informatik und muss mich langsam entscheiden
in welche richtung ich mich orientieren will datenverarbeitung aka big data und webentwicklung
oder spiele und spiele design und spiele programmierung da kann ich dir nicht helfen
bei da kann ich die entscheidung kann ich dir glaube ich nichts nichts gutes dazu raten
also wenn ihr also v-skatze gefällt beides gleich gleich beides gleich gleich gut ja weil
das was du im studium da lernst ist jetzt ja nicht unbedingt das was du später was du
später 100 prozentig machen wirst keine ahnung keine ahnung da kann ich wirklich nichts
zu sagen was hältst du von macbooks ich finde ich finde die meiste apple hardware eigentlich
ganz gut allerdings viel zu teuer und auch viel zu eingeschränkt ich würde auch mit
mac os nicht klarkommen als main betriebssystem wenn ich von windows weg könnte würde ich
linux verwenden allerdings kann ich von windows nicht weg also kann ich auch kein mac verwenden
und wenn auf mac installieren kann ich mir auch gleich irgendwas anderes zusammenbauen
habe ich mir auch habe ich hier vorgenommen ja dass wir in nächster zeit auch ein bisschen
git magic zusammen machen ist ich das ist aus irgendeiner dummen rtl sendung wenn ich
doch zusammen krieg piss dich alle ist das ist das das hier noch wo sagt er piss dich
alle piss dich alle genau piss dich alle das ist so dumm
piss dich alle das können wir das können wir echt hinzufügen ja das ist gut ok erstmal
runterladen erstmal fünf schmalier verzeichnis wechsel youtube dl und dann als als welches
format müssen wir das runterladen als hier m4a meinetwegen ne 140 halbwegs guter quali
runterladen so und jetzt ffm pack input piss dich alde output piss dich waff explore piss
dich all piss dich waff ja da ist es doch piss dich aldo perfekt so dann machen wir
das mal hier rein piss dich aldo ja funktioniert sehr gut so langsam aber sicher haben wir
die essentials haben wir drinnen youtube dl funktioniert bei dir oft nicht bei mir macht
er also ich weiß es immer doof verantwortung nach dem motto ja ich habe keine probleme
aber ich habe glaube ich noch nicht ein video nicht runterladen können mit youtube dl einfach
mal einfach mal updaten die das aber so wenn du eine alte version hast backt das öfters
rum aber das ist ein programm was erstaunlich wenig probleme macht hast du auf rocket beans
gesehen die machen eine sendung wo sie programmieren für einschneid das habe ich nicht gesehen
zeigt mal wo ist das wo ist das das da wo ist der editor wo ist der ich muss ich muss
den editor sehen hier wie es coach okay oh big bra gut jeder fängt mal so an wahnsinn
das kriegt man aber auch nach dem ersten tutorial gebacken das war es gibt es da noch mehr
seine playlist zu
so seit über 14 tagen keine ah doch es war zwei tagen okay was machen sie sonst noch
so programmieren jetzt werden bisschen javascript funktion gemacht okay was ich ja was ich ja
schon wieder bisschen grinch grinch ich finde ist man sollte den leuten gar nicht beibringen
deutsche variable namen zu verwenden zu verwenden man sollte gleich sagen nenn den kram ordentlich
und die korrekte variante in javascript wäre an der stelle sogar kebab case also zweite
minus zahl ja und das heißt wirklich kebab case wobei bei variable namen bin ich mir
gar nicht sicher variablen variablen in javascript auch kebab kein ach keine ahnung meine variable
namen sind eh viel besser so was wie temp oder i oder blub ich meine bindestrich habe
ich anders gesagt ich meine bindestrich also ihr kennt meine variable namen die sind eindeutig
superior die sind excellent die machen die machen kein kalt die rechnen sachen zusammen
aber in dem tempo weitermachen wollen kommt das dauert ganz schön lang bis da was ordentliches
rauskommt am ende ich bin eine zeichenkette massive let us aktiviert gleich true das ist
false was jetzt bin ich mal gespannt jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob es den leuten gleich
ordentlich zeigen jetzt bin ich mal gespannt ob es den leuten gleich ordentlich zeigen
oder ob es oder wie sie es if schreiben falls sie überhaupt ein if machen weil die meisten
noobs die meisten noobs schreiben if ist aktiviert gleich gleich true das ist auch im kopf
erstmal irgendwie das logische das kann man schon zeigen dass man das so schreiben kann
aber danach sollte man den auch gleich zeigen dass man das gleich gleich true einfach weglässt
weil es kommt das gleiche raus warum ist es denn kein konst ja man kann es ja auch gleich
übertreiben wann wann kommt das if es gibt es in den overflow ne oder ach ja was gibt
okay was jetzt bin ich mal gespannt was da rauskommt if zweite gleich gleich
null meine augen meine augen warum denn in notepad es ist gar kein notepad ist das notepad plus
plus den notepad 2 mod ist das sogar nicht dass das existiert oh jetzt wird erstmal
noch js installiert ah die verbindung ist abgebrochen ok deutschland deutschland und
internet mark zu notepad plus plus nicht doch das ist ok das kann man verwenden wenn man
was braucht was wirklich schnell startet und man nicht auf wie es kaut warten kann ja aber
ich finde es gut dass sie sowas machen die haben eine gewisse reichweite ich finde es
immer schön wenn mehr leute sich für das thema interessieren unter dem schritt kann
es ja nur mehr nur mir zugute kommen dann schlagen vielleicht ein paar mehr leute bei
mir im stream auf und werden teil des was aber sehr unwahrscheinlich ist dass einer
von dem rocket beans video bei mir jetzt auf twitch aufschlägt außerdem machen wir gar
kein programmierzeug was magst du notepad plus plus nicht gar nichts also die habe ich
gerade schon mal antworten ist kann man verwenden hast du die clipboard history an nein habe
ich nicht an oder doch mehr gibt es nicht ich habe die clipboard history an
hörst du spezielle musik beim programmieren ja mache ich es kommt ein bisschen drauf an
also ich habe da so zwei zwei betriebsmodis nennen wir es mal so ich habe einmal die sache
wo ich mich sehr auf einzelne probleme konzentrieren muss die kompliziert sind dann mache ich meistens
entweder sowas hier an irgendwie sowas da collection mix 2019 oder sowas sowas hier
das finde ich eigentlich ganz entspannt sowas manchmal mache ich auch irgendwelche klassik
an das ist aber wenn ich mich auf einzelne sachen konzentrieren muss und und die kompliziert
sind dann mache ich meistens so an und wenn ich eher so im generellen architektur mode
bin wo ich mir wo ich mir so gedanken mache was ich so was braucht man da vielleicht für
klassen welche technik nimmt man da da habe ich entweder gar nichts an oder zeugs was
ich sonst auch höre lautsprecher oder immer kopfhörer eigentlich immer kopfhörer deswegen
das ist auch der der moment wo ich da die die super bequemen kopfhörer anziehe die
ich euch letztens mal gezeigt habe und ich dachte schon max hört heavy metal beim programmieren
da bei so normalen architektursachen oder wo ich einfach nur ein bisschen nachdenke
und gucke wie man es machen könnte da läuft das normale zeug was ich sonst so höre also
das kann dann alles mögliche sein das kann dann das kann dann bis zu bis zu dem hier
gehen es kann dann bis zu dem hier gehen any bangers aber das ist nicht die richtige
programmieren musik das übelst geil dass man einer der besten dass das ist das
richtig um sql zu programmieren leute das ist das beste für cobalt mit dem tag programmiert
vor in feil da das kannst du nicht im tag programmieren ja für sql ist das sicherlich
auch sehr nice ich mein für dba ist für datenbank admins der beste titel schlechthin oder ich
hoffe das nimmt kein datenbank admins ernst hier alles vorbei flash komplett dd def null
str drop table genau alles weg ich fand für so esoterische sprache wie brainfuck wäre
es vielleicht auch nicht schlecht habe ich schon mal gesagt dass dass der dass die musik
echt gut ist es ist nicht jedermanns sache aber wenn man auf so vikinger zeug steht ist
das einer der besten songs überhaupt all die meistens stehen ja nicht auf vikinger sachen
und solche dinger die meisten hören sich lieber keine ahnung aporet an oder so oder
was auch immer da gerade angesagt ist der refreuer ist halt so nice die würd ich mir
gerne nochmal mal das
Ryu
live gesehen enttäuschen
lass mich mal raten
ich rate mal was dich enttäuscht hat
du kannst mir sagen ob das stimmt
ich vermute mal, dass man
hier verstehst du noch halbwegs was
ich denke mal
dass man live
vocal mäßig
gesang mäßig
nichts checkt
und es auch nicht harmonisch dazu passt
ich weiß nicht ob da
gesang gut hinkommt live
das könnte ich mir vorstellen dass es ein bisschen
problematisch ist
ansonsten
was hat dir denn nicht gefallen
wacken fällt aus, ja stimmt
die gamescom fällt auch aus
bei dem genre kommt es auf
gesang an ja
so blöds klingt ja
was hältst du von alestorm
oder sind die pirates
ja die haben auch ein paar coole sachen
aber da habe ich
nichts neueres
gehört bisher
von denen
also was die in den letzten jahren gemacht haben keine ahnung
weiß nicht
gamescom findet digital statt
da bin ich ja mal gespannt wenn wir in deutschland
eine messe rein digital ausrichten wollen
da habe ich ja so meine bedenken
dass das
gut funktioniert
wir sind ja was digital angeht
vorne mit dabei immer
von unten betrachtet
das erste was passieren wird ist wenn die gamescom
der gamescom stream online geht
erstmal monka smoke geht erstmal nicht mehr
genau erstmal
weg
so
das haben wir jetzt ausführlich beantwortet
kennst du dich mit kabelnetzen aus nein
keine ahnung
merkel wave
zum teufel ist merkel wave
nee
wat
das ist irgendein trollversuch
den ich nicht checke
alles auf masterforce
ne das ist nicht was ich unter gitmagic verstehen würde
oh jetzt ist hier big brain time
vom flow 690 angesagt
warum steht da so viel kek w im chat
wobei da nur einmal kek w vorkommt
was hältst du vor microsoft surface
finde ich gut
wir haben auf der arbeit
ein paar surface
wie heißen die books tablets
und auch diese
surface bildschirme
die sind wirklich nice
sag nichts böses dann sind wir sauer
ne finde ich gut
dein professor nennt seine getter setzer
und geber
exquisite
der mag alles auf deutsch
setzer und geber
warum geber und nicht holer
aber das ist
ja mein wenn er da drauf steht
habe neulich in production code
tatsächlich die variable temp
und danach die variable temp temp verwendet
ich mach das laufend
auch wenn es nicht schön aussieht
manchmal wenn du in bestehende
sachen was rein quetschen musst
warum nicht
also temp temp
kommt selten vor
aber bei mir heißt es
meistens so die erste variable
ist tmp und dann hab ich noch ne temp
und eventuell noch ne blub
ich glaube das sind so meine
vielleicht noch i
i ist auch noch dabei
ich glaub diese kombi sind meine
wa
meistverwendeten
variable namen
tmp temp blub und i
ne e verwende ich nicht
nach i kommt immer j
ah
wir verstehen uns
ja klar
ich hab selten so
nested schleifen dass ich 3
variablen für brauche
das sind so meine
meist benutzten variablen
und
und mittlerweile ist das schlimme meine
teststrings ist oftmals der da
ist kein witz
wenn ihr es bei uns sehen könntet
es gibt ein paar scripts
und ein paar sachen wo als default
text keqw drin steht
keqw sorry
keq
u